I'm usually professional blackjack
player and a former member of the MIT
car counting team I'm here to answer
your question from Twitter this is
Casino Arts support
[Music]
first up I am roulette Stark what casino
games has the best odds if you don't
have any skills the best odds is by far
baccarat you will lose about 50 cents
for every 100 you put out if you play
for a long time you still lose money
it's still the least amount of money you
can lose if you have no skills the best
game out there if you do have skill I
believe is Blackjack if you are a
regular player you walk into a casino
you lose somewhere around 1.50 to three
dollars per hundred dollar that you bet
if you are professional blackjack
players you will be able to win a dollar
fifty to three dollars from the casino
the other way around from react GPT what
is the worst casino game in terms of
odds there's no question the worst game
in a casino are the slot machines us
range of anywhere between 80 to 99
payout that means when you put a hundred
dollar in you may only get eighty
dollars out or 99 out the next question
is from boom loaded can Casino kick you
out for winning too much most of the
casino don't kick you out for winning
because they believe the law of large
number will eventually help the casino
win back any money that you've won in
the short period of time this is the
concept that in statistics no matter how
random something is when you do a lot of
these random events together at some
point there is a norm that comes out
that's called the larger number however
if a casino found out you are a
professional and you have an edge over
the casino the only law on the book that
a casino can kick a player out is
through the trespass log then they will
kick you out and in fact they have to
otherwise they will go bankrupt
Nighthawk KZ how is the house Edge
calculator every game has a different
Edge and the way they do this is through
what's called a Monte Carlo simulations
you simulate millions and millions of
these hands and based on that simulation
and the outcome you can compute what
they expected win or losses this is how
a professional Blackjack team figured
out what is that optimal hand to play
two Bob squirt getting no luck at all in
the roulette is there a trick to it
unfortunately there's no way to win in a
roulette as is and part of the the
reason is
you can bet red or black if it lands in
these greens you'll basically lose the
reason the casino have an edge over the
player in roulette is are these two
green numbers here there is however a
way to win in roulette and that happens
when you step into a very old not well
maintained Casino where the roulette
wheel itself is not balanced when it's
not balanced there are parts of the
wheel that get less probable of of a
chance of Landing the ball in the slots
along that area and then you observe
that over a long period of time you can
actually beat the casino by just
eliminating as little as two to three
numbers Casino bloke what are the odds
of winning slot machines how does
volatility work in slots in some states
the range to which is legally allowed
for the casino to set the dial could be
as low as 80 and as high as 99 that
means you know for every 100 you bet the
casino could set it so that you will win
back only 80 out of it so slot machines
has a dial that casino can tweak and
create the odds that they want for their
business they don't change these numbers
easily it requires a whole committee to
to come down and agreed on this is what
they need to do but in the in a more
sort of off strip Shady Casino we have
her story from insiders that busy you
know Super Bowl nights and whatnot they
literally crank up this so they can make
more money the next question is from
data36.com why are people losing at
casinos they ignore a few statistical
Concepts like expected value hot hand
fallacy probability in general think of
expected value as the mathematical truth
of how much money you are winning on
losing most of the player in the casino
most of the game you have a negative
expected value that means over time love
large number will take over and you will
lose money hot hand fallacy is the
concept of streaks a lot of players when
they set the table they keep winning and
when they're winning they're like I'm in
a hot streaks when in reality every hand
is completely independent but randomly
over a short period of time you could
have lots of winning hints one after
another and again the concept of of all
of these is during the math of
probability the law number eventually
takes over the expected win or lose
eventually play out the next question is
from Kata feather what is the best
blackjack strategy there's actually a
perfect way to play
your hand and the perfect way is that
based on the cards you have in front of
you against the face up card from the
dealer there's a mathematical way that
pair in these wins and I have here a
pretty standard what's called a basic
strategy chart you can Google these and
find a lot of variations of it and by
the way there's small variations of
these depends on different casinos
different rules they have there's a
slight variation but if you don't know
how to count cards
and you memorize what to do with each
hand against every single combination of
the Dealer's hand you will minimize your
loss in blackjack down to around 60
cents per 100 RTA Chris I'm not gonna
ask how to do it but how does car
counting work the principle of car
counting is really around tracking how
much face cards and aces are left and
the rationale is that
when there are more Aces there's a
higher chance of either the player or
the dealer hitting Blackjack except in
most casinos if the player hit Blackjack
they could pay a time and a half when
the dealer hit Blackjack they just give
you money right so because you have that
time and had Advantage when when there's
higher odds to hit blackjack player has
an edge that's one and two the rule of
blackjacks the dealer has to hit their
hand until 17. when there's a lot of
face cards left in the shoe the dealer
will bust more often ads 69 why do
casinos kick you out when you do car
counting this is not cheating it is a
skill it is not cheating right we're
using our brain that's why it's
completely legal in the state of New
Jersey
casinos are not allowed to kick players
out so they have other means of ruining
the game for us so for example in the
game of blackjack they will put the cut
cards way up in the front so that you
basically cannot possibly count in with
some Casino will use what's called
continuous Shuffle machine where they
have a machine that shuffles the car uh
continuously in those situations there's
really no way you can beat the casino
trading Sumo one why do casinos have
table limits if the odds are in their
favor table limits are set up to bust a
particular type of algorithm called the
Martingale algorithm and the algorithm
goes like this I bet a dollar if I win
I'm gonna take the dollar I win and
re-bed a dollar but if I lose a hand I'm
gonna double my bet if I stack away the
wins I have and for every hand I lose I
double eventually the streak of losing
will will break otherwise if you have a
lot of money if I'm a billionaire I can
go to the casino just use that algorithm
that can make money while food diet
tours does crab have any type of
advantage to play unfortunately you can
never win in crap however there is a
loophole in some of the casinos in the
following way so in crap you have the
initial bet and after the initial bet if
the roller didn't hit uh seven you will
have a follow-on bit the follow-on bets
are even odds there's no advantage to
the casino or the player in the
follow-on bits so one strategy with
plane craps is you back bet anybody else
so if you have a friend or even a
stranger who put the initial bet as a
hundred dollars and you can have the
secondary pack going forward in in that
round if you can bet as much money as
possible on the set on the second bet up
to the maximum allowed by the casino and
that's even not that means you can play
for a long period of time and
theoretically you won't lose money and
if you get a drink for free you come out
of here click to launch what is your
best poker strategy the best poker
strategy is to get really really good at
poker to begin with in non-tournament
poker the way you win money is to
frankly sit around tables with other
players who are not as skilled as you
and have a lot of money to lose your
formal teammates of ours who retire from
Blackjack end up building a software
that he used to monitor all the online
poker sites that he can get into and
basically screen scrape and look at all
the different tables that's out there
and the algorithm rings a bell for him
when he detect that there is somebody
who's not that good and have a lot of
money to throw around and rings a bell
he jump into those tables and beat them
and take take their money vubalpop how
do they catch cheaters in Las Vegas
there are some casinos that have RFID
embedded chips in the actual chips that
have been put out and the main purpose
is not to catch car counters or or
cheats but it's really to keep track of
how much money the player put out
because that's the way the compute and
figure out what type of perks or what
type of players or detecting whales Etc
and sometimes through those RFID chips
they can detect an harmonies from the
statistics they're seeing and from those
they will flag this player and people
will then pay more attention to them and
to make sure there's no cheating going
on Bob volcano you think every slot
machine has the same Arts the answer is
no there's tons of different slot
machines now technically there is a type
of slot machine you can actually make
money all right and that is uh part of a
a whole class of slot machine called
progressive slot machine you may have
seen this in Casino where the concept is
basically over time as the player lose
money the the machine build up a bank
uh and and the payout increases over
time but once somebody win a jackpot or
certain combination it empties out the
bank so theoretically if you walk up to
a machine over a certain threshold this
machine will actually pay out more than
the money you're paying so the strategy
for these Progressive machines is that
you walk up to the machine you look at
how much is in the bank if it's above a
certain number you basically play that
machine until the bank breaks sick
cheesy I lost 400 at a roulette table in
10 minutes last night what are the odds
there were eight Reds in a row the odds
of eight Reds in a row is 2 to the power
of 8 which is 256 so it's 1 out of 256
time you will have eight rates in a row
it's very unfortunate sorry to hear that
Tim Sim Cox one gambling at casinos is
voluntarily participating in a game that
is opening of knowledge to be rigged why
do people do it there are people who uh
actually value the thrill of making
money a whole lot more than the misery
of losing money those are the true
gamblers when they make a hundred
dollars they are so much more happier
than if they lose a hundred dollars by
the way most people are the other way
around if you lose 100 you feel a whole
lot worse than the joy of winning a
hundred dollar and usually that's how
you can tell whether somebody's a
gambler or not from bang schwaf which
casino game makes the house the most
money for most casinos the game that
make the most money are the slot
machines and the reason the slot
machines make Casino money is there's no
labor involved you can set up you know
hundreds of these machines and they're
just there taking up electricity but
they're making money every hour that
there's a player uh sitting in front of
them Stephen Walton why do you always
split Aces and eights in blackjack if
you got two Aces the Monte Carlo
simulation says you're better off
splitting those Aces so that the two
hands that you result in will give you
higher odds of winning because you know
all you need is a face card and one of
them to get the highest possible which
is 21. the other one is when you have an
ace you can double down if it's a
favorable hand against the dealer so you
always split that and eight is the same
thing when you split two eights you have
a higher chance again mathematically to
to come up more favorable him however
the one caveat I would say is that if
the casino you know offer surrender
surrender is a little known rules
surrender is the concept that if I bet
100 and I say surrender I only have to
give the dealer fifty dollars I take
half of my money back so if I have two
AIDS the rule surrender exists in that
casino you will say surrender and you
you let the other half back if the
dealer has a face car an ace or nine or
the situation you would split the Gate
lift emotion can machine learning guess
your poker face so the way the machine
will be able to pick out are these tells
uh you know maybe touches or how long
you gaze out your cards and so forth all
these little nuances that frankly
skill poker player relied on to beat
other poker players but at the end of
the day I can totally see if you focus
machine learning and image recognition
or facial expression on individuals that
over time I can I can totally see how
that you can have a algorithm that's
tuned on individual players Irish Norse
woman how do you lose money owning
Casino if you think about the odds of
winning for Casino it's still very tiny
you know Casino may be the regular
player three percent of the time at the
same time the other side of the Ledger
is they're spending tons of money
entertaining guests you know restaurants
lights utilities even though casino
games by purely just a casino part of
the business itself could be making tons
of money if you don't manage the other
part of the business you could still
lose money that's all the questions hope
you learned something from this and good
luck in your next adventure in casinos